bonjour marianne le souhait merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur ert france alors
tout d'abord quelle est la situation
dans le collège où vous enseignez
constatez-vous beaucoup de contamination
alors qu'elle cartonne que on a vraiment
eu une augmentation très nette du nombre
de cas dans l'est les deux dernières
semaines alors des cas il n est aussi
vraiment des cas adultes enoch la
situation est très compliquée la semaine
dernière on avait deux agents de service
alors même qu'on nous demande un
protocole sanitaire renforcée que
l'étape doivent être nettoyés les
familles vers bagdad deux agents en
service
mardi dernier les enseignants ont exercé
leur droit de retrait en se sentant pas
en sécurité ni pour eux ni pour lens des
bed et du coup leur famille et bien sûr
parce que les élèves le poème qui ont
contaminé leurs proches
on demandait encore ce jour-là mardi
dernier pour éviter d'être obligé de
complètement fermée qu'on nous mette des
deux classes ce qui permet quand même de
temps d'observer beaucoup plus de
distance entre les élèves les deux me
classe nous ont été refusées par le gaz
et du 93 résultats mercredi de confirmer
jeudi deux eaux et aujourd'hui on en est
à 7
donc on dieu que ce soit des enfants qui
viennent effectivement en alternance en
du litre on quand on ferme des classes
et devient du coup ses deux enfants qui
ne viennent plus il délaisse qui nous
aiment plus du tout voilà et donc pour
vous donner un pull et la semaine
dernière la principale et projets de
plus la principale adwan pareil la
tendance pareil da silva voilà qui était
vraiment au monde the perriand pas les
gens sont pas là et ça ça s'ajoute au
passé l'âge entendu que monsieur
bancaire est lui qui va les mettre des
remplaçants mais depuis le début de
l'année on a deux enseignants s'ils sont
absents qui sont une autorisation
spécifique d'absence si c'était des gens
qui sont d'ulm érables voilà et bien
c'est depuis le début d'année elle des
classes qui ont nico de français nicosie
sorriaux
et voilà et si ça n'est pas méprise et
on est en retraite plus à voile alors si
c'est pas mépriser les enfants ne
devraient plus qu'on ait besoin au
contraire voilà que leur nom soit un
présent et remplacé en premier lieu
voilà c'est l'éducation nationale et les
prix pour les élèves de 4 e prix alors
jean michel blanc coeur qui a également
annoncé qu'à partir de demain une classe
sera fermée de le premier cas de
contamination détecté dans les
départements où le virus est le plus
active ce qui pourrait donc engendrer
des fermetures de classes plus
importante dans le département où vous
vous trouvez quelle est la meilleure
solution est ce que aujourd'hui vous
vous demandez vous aussi à tout
simplement fermer les écoles le temps
que cette épidémie baisse un petit peu
là moi alors j'ai pas tellement
d'individualités de t'avoir au point où
on en est nous taper longtemps ont
demandé de me joindre la communauté dans
l'élite et ont des deux groupes pour
diminuer la pression du nombre de
d'enfants par classe
les membres dans les lettres dans les
couloirs justement on demandait ça pour
éviter la fermeture vous et là
effectivement on le doit bien à nous
refuser cette mesure aujourd'hui c'est
des classes qui tient la ville après les
autres 4 la traîne derrière deux de plus
vendredi et dans ce week end là un mail
du ciel d'établissement une de plus qui
terme donc alors est ce que est ce que
ça va suffire
ou est-ce que de ça tombe à faire les 4
est-ce que c'est pas pour dire qu elle
est ouvert et de toute façon on va quand
même chez nous va s'arrêter près que la
beauté des classes et établissements
fermés alors qu'il a le dit mardi on en
tire le une une une on pourra dire qu'on
est resté envers les autres a fermé en
réalité quoi donc voilà après moi je ne
suis pas du tout évident et biologiques
et j'ai aucune idée de moi j'ai pas
d'idée savoir la mesure qui sera
efficace comme je vois je pense juste
que moins d'élèves étaient commandés
permettait surtout surtout de rester
ouvert à priori moi je n'étais pas pour
la fermeture
mais qu'a fait que mon point de vue
personnel je pense que n est laide
il doit apprendre et ils font qu'il soit
quotidienne au collège voilà mes donc
justement c'était tout faire pour qu'il
puisse continuer le plus loin possible
du nom tu en penses quoi toi avancer là
as tu des vacances scolaires comme cela
avait été proposé par la présidente de
la région ile de france valérie pécresse
est ce que ça peut être une solution
peut-être oui peut-être
honnêtement tout d'abord j'ai vraiment
il ya beaucoup de cas oui bah peut-être
avant tout donc au retour tapera pas
fait oui peut-être
dernière question dans le lycée eugène
delacroix à drancy 20 20 élèves ont déjà
perdu un parent en raison du coc vide 19
d'ailleurs les enseignants de ce lycée
ont adressé une lettre au président de
la république pour demander la fermeture
de l'établissement
on sait que depuis mardi ils exercent
également leur droit de retrait que vous
évoque cette situation dans ce lycée oui
mais oui je comprends bien pour que nous
aussi ma vie quand on a exercé leur
droit de retrait les collègues les
enseignants ont témoigné en tic au bout
d'un moment de leur inquiétude du fait
qu'on se sentait pas en sécurité
en venant travailler donc on est inquiet
pour les proches de nos délais de leurs
parents et ont des efforts mais
également inquiet pour pour nous oui
bien sûr que non pendant la première
bague on a eu des familles qui étaient
touchés
donc bien sûr que bien sûr que c'étaient
de vraies responsabilités pour le
gouvernement un port militaire
d'éducation d'un canal qui sont lourdes
à porter de dire que parce que on a
voulu car le fier-à-bras une baisse de
forme par le terme parle de ferme pas
comme on arrive à des décès c'est
compliqué je répète frappes à plat merci
beaucoup en tout cas marianne le saut
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes professeur au
collège lenain-de-tillemont en seine
saint denis